If your inner songbird just won't sing, in key that is,...
...follow these tips to become a singing starling.
You will need a voice, ears, and a vocal coach.
Optional: water.
Step one: Breathe deeply and with your diaphragm.
This will take practice, patience, and stomach muscles.
Strengthen your stomach with exercises such as sit-ups.
Step two: Stand up straight when warming up for a song.
Practice in front of the mirror.
Step three: Relax your shoulders, loosen your muscles and get ready to project your soul.
Step four: Warm up your voice by putting your lips together and vibrating them like a horse.
While making that noise, sing scales.
Avoid dairy products or thick beverages before performances and drink a lot of water.
Step five: Listen to other vocal performances and try to mimic the performer,...
...this will help train your voice and your ear.
Step six: Hire a professional vocal coach if you feel you need additional instruction.
This person can offer you valuable tips and set you on your way to becoming a soaring songbird.
Did you know? Most people are capable of three octaves.
Exceptional talents are known to reach four or five octaves, but that is very rare.